[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Rob Siegel,
lecturer of management at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I teach six different courses at the GSB,
but today, we're going to talk about
the key takeaways from one of them,
the industrialist's dilemma.
[MUSIC]
What's different about
the industrialist's dilemma is that,
the combination of physical and
digital is completely different than
anything that's happened before.
And it's increasing the speed with
which markets are able to change.
And it also enables new companies to end
into markets that previously would not
have been able to.
And you can study every industry to see
how the combination of hardware and
software, digital and physical, are being
impacted by these technological and
business model changes.
One of the things we've learned in
studying the industrialist's dilemma is
that neither incumbents nor
disruptors are necessarily
preordained to win in the market.
Disruptors have a blank sheet of paper,
they can think with a clean slate about
how they're going to meet customer needs,
but they often don't have the domain
knowledge of what it takes to be
successful in a particular market.
Incumbents often have deep balance sheets,
but they need to move more quickly and
build skill and
competencies that maybe they haven't
had previously in their organization.
[MUSIC]
In a world where every
product is connected,
companies need to keep in mind two things.
Number one, they need to develop
the capabilities to write the software to
communicate with the customers, and then
the how to manage it on an ongoing basis.
To listen to conversations with customers,
to understand how customers are using
their products, and to think about how
they can constantly improving their
products, to delight customers and
thinking about customer outcomes.
At the same time, organizations need to
understand that the entire ecosystem might
be jealous of that
ongoing conversation and
relationship between maybe a company that
manufactures something and the end user.
And people in a channel might want to be
a part of that data stream going back
and forth.
[MUSIC]
In a world where digital and physical
are combining to create massive disruption
across industries, somebody is
going to end up being the underdog and
somebody is going to be on their heels.
Being an underdog can
actually be very liberating.
In some ways, when you're on your heels,
you have nothing to lose and
you have a license to try new things and
be very creative.
You can look at ways in which headwinds
can actually become tailwinds,
that can actually propel you forward.
So a change in a technology,
a change in an industry, could actually be
an opportunity for a company to catapult
itself to do business in a new way.
An example of a company that
turned a headwind into a tailwind,
is the North American
electronics retailer Best Buy.
Eight years ago their product was
being commoditized, everybody was
buying televisions, and telephones online
and just trying to get the lowest price.
But as all of these products became
increasingly connected to the internet,
their level of complexity went up.
What Best Buy figured out is, they could
be the best service retailer not just
selling the box themselves, but making
sure the customers knew how to connect
them to the networks and to each other
to deliver a better customer experience.
[MUSIC]
Companies that innovate on
both new technologies and
new business models end up
becoming the winners long term.
A great example is Align Technologies,
the people who make the clear in
this align teeth straightening tool.
The technology behind
the clear plastic aligners,
is very difficult to manufacture.
But what they did really well,
is they also increased their channels,
selling not only through orthodontists but
through dentists, which very much expanded
the market and allowed adults to start
using the product and not just teenagers.
What we found is that having
business model innovation and
technological innovation,
was a real force multiplier.
And doing only one of these, was necessary
but not sufficient for long term success.
[MUSIC]
As companies from the technology industry
moving to things like health care and
financial services, they start getting in
the areas where governments increasingly
regulates these areas.
In addition, it starts to get
to national industrial policy.
Leaders of companies for the next several
decades, are going to have to be very
conversant in how to work with and
collaborate with governments all over
the world and know how to be successful
in a world that's increasingly complex.
[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Rob.
I'm the short bald
guy in front of the class.
I have a linebacker's mindset, and
I used to carry around books that were
this thick when I was in high school.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]